hey guys I'm Hannah Bronfman I'm the
founder of a wellness destination site
called HP fit comm I have my first book
coming out this January called do what
feels good recipes routines and remedies
to treat your body right I'm gonna
showcase blue magic
it's an extract of spirulina which I'm
sure you guys are kind of familiar with
it's chock full of antioxidants so I'm
going to show you how I like to use it
leave a secret ingredient in here called
pearl powder it's very good for cell
rejuvenation and making it a very very
Beauty rich ingredient
[Music]
he's gonna give this another like five
more seconds but it looks pretty good
[Music]
here you have your Blue Magic Beauty
butter tastes great on any sorts of
fruits on any sort of granolas spread on
a piece of toast and you are getting all
the antioxidant and you defined benefits
of Blue Magic and pearl powder full
disclaimer I just want to let you know
now that I understand that blue magic
smells smells like fish food don't
forget it's blue-green algae it comes
from our ocean they can guarantee you it
tastes nothing like how it smells
in fact it's so delicious I'm gonna eat
it with a spoon
[Music]
so this is an alternative way of using
blue magic but this time in the form of
a cocktail I love a good drink but we
all know that drinking causes
inflammation and blue magic is
anti-inflammatory so I decided to use it
in a cocktail that's super delicious and
let's give it a go
[Applause]
so this is kind of a take on a pina
colada
just because of the ice and the
passionfruit in the coconut then you've
got this vibrant color of the Blue Magic
excellent
[Music]
this cocktail is called the Blue Agave
and that is because I use tequila which
is from an agave plant this is kind of
my take on a mule mules are not
traditionally served with tequila
but I love a tequila mule and so this is
kind of like my own version of that
[Music]
[Music]
and I'm just gonna add one splash of
bitters just at the end
this literally tastes like a fresh
tequila mule I mean it's got the ginger
it's got a little bit of the orange and
it that you can taste the color is
gorgeous again you can't really taste
the Blue Magic but you're getting all
the benefits of it so that concludes my
blue magic segment for today and I hope
you guys get a chance to check out these
different cocktails and recipes using
this superfood ingredient and that's all
for now
[Music]